hey welcome back guys code vlogs episode
16.
also looks like this is going to be the
final episode of the series and i'll
explain that in a little bit but uh
first we're going to talk about what
we're working on currently and where
we're at
so there's often a bit of a spread out
in these episodes and sometimes a lot of
stuff happens in between that i don't
really record
but uh mainly what we're doing in this
one since we did already come out with
uh 0.006 yeah that version is out and
usable but as i kind of went to test it
and use it i started to make a new
project and started to use this library
i realized something somewhat critical
to the experience and use of it that i
need to change and that all has to do
with the main public header there's a
main public header that you use when you
use this library just saying archer.h
kinda has all the core stuff to get
everything going for all the
functionality and i fully documented it
made a github pages of it and so yeah
the documentation is up on a page now
and if you just use the library you
should be able to hover over your
functions with your intellisense and it
should tell you all the definitions of
what you're using as well so that should
make it a good use more usable but i had
this problem where i had all these
includes they're not here now i took
them out that were private so when you
copy over this includes folder you would
get a bunch of errors saying hey your
library can't find this file
so all those private headers
are going to private and we're going to
only have
pointers of them with four declarations
in this header i think this is the way
to do it
and because of this we're also going to
be using a good bit
of unique pointers
we don't want to manually handle every
little thing but we do know in most
cases here for our stuff that's going on
in the engine we don't want people to be
copying it and managing it it's going to
manage its own memory and for 90 of the
cases when it goes out of scope it
should delete so unique pointer
and that's going to be great because
yeah we got to use pointers since we
don't want to include all the details of
the object it just needs to happen
behind the scenes if that doesn't make a
whole lot of sense well
i guess it comes with time it's not
something i understood well when i was a
new z plus plus programmer
but it is something that needs to happen
in my case it looks like in order to
make this properly usable because i
don't know about you guys but i'm ready
to actually like build something i'm
getting kind of tired of working on the
back end as much as i love it i want to
build something to see where i'm at and
then go from there before adding more
but i did say this was going to be the
last episode
at least for season one and at least for
agent archer let me explain ancient
archer is my own personal project just
just me it's not something that's
specifically for this code channel i
just chose to put it on here because
it's code related and allows a lot of
code talk we'll say
however
i have a bit of mixed feelings about
this whole putting it on the channel to
be honest i don't know if it's a good
idea i decided it was fine ultimately
because this is a public repo i could in
theory put stuff on my channel like this
about any particular repo
i just chose to use one i'm familiar
with and one that i'm building because i
can talk about a lot better and a lot
more than i could someone else's project
that i'm trying to figure out on the fly
as far as like the inner workings and
everything all right and i did say in
episode 15 that uh at some point i said
hey go give this a star for every star
it's after this video i'll make another
vlog that didn't sit too well there are
no new stars which tells me that nobody
particularly cares uh about this project
other than me which is fine i'm sure and
i don't mean that
quite literally like i know some people
do care to some extent but not enough to
like ever take action they're not gonna
help with the project they're not gonna
support the project some some might and
that's awesome but like
since last video i kind of had the
realization that i'm on my own with this
i already knew that but it just kind of
like really set in and that being the
case i don't need to do anything i don't
want to do i don't need to listen to
anybody it's kind of a good feeling but
also it kind of sucks when you realize
no one cares but that also is just life
if you look at philosophy in general
you'll find out that yeah one of the
cruxes of life and one of the big
counters to anxiety yes your anxiety
doesn't matter no one cares if you have
it or don't have it and here's why
because in general people don't care and
that's a good thing because it's free
you can do what you want and like most
people just aren't going to care so use
that to your advantage this is not an
original thought i heard it from someone
else
so take that for what you will but in my
case i get to do what i want with this
engine and this
these vlogs
so yeah i don't have a big backing or
support anyway what i'm going to do is
i'm going to make this i'm going to
clean it up 0-7 is probably going to be
the last one that i work on publicly
because this is going to go to a private
space i'm in theory going to sell it to
my company who is going to develop it
privately i might hire developers to
help on it but at first it's just going
to be me the first thing i'm going to do
is i'm going to transition it to a cmake
project make it cross platform and we're
going to add in the vulcan renderer
we're going to upgrade everything and
it's just going to move forward but this
public one is no longer going to be
worked on however i will put a little
stipulation in there i'm going to put
like a like a fundraiser on this thing
and say hey if we hit this amount i'll
start developing it publicly again and
what should this number be now i
question this a lot and i just had to
ask myself some questions
so given the case that most people
aren't particularly concerned about this
project or what's going on or what it's
doing no one's
even if i ask for support in general i'm
not going to get support
kind of realized that last video
anyone that's going to look at this
project and
i guess i i feel like most people are
just going to want to learn from it and
it's fine there's also going to be a
rather large chunk of people that just
want results they want to be able to
steal from it put it in their own thing
say they did it you know that sort of
thing which you know breaks the license
and isn't a good thing to do actually i
don't think it breaks the license
because i think i put mit or something
on it so they can do whatever they want
as long as i believe they have to give
credit i don't even know i'm not real
fond of trying to figure out what all
the licenses are i just don't care to be
honest but also i don't want people
stealing my stuff and trying to take
credit for it because i didn't have the
proper license or something so my
solution to that is oh let's go to law
school learn all about licenses spend
six years of my life learning about
licenses because that's apparently what
it takes to understand all this stuff
and read all the fine print and i'm just
gonna say no i don't i'm not a lawyer
i'm a programmer i wanna program i don't
wanna read your fine text unless it has
to do with how the software works
or how the memory works or something you
know so yeah i'm going to stop
developing this it's kind of in a broken
state that's fine there's a lot to learn
from it there's a lot that can be
optimized and proved if people want to
work on it awesome i'll uh allow people
to work on it that's fine
but as far as my work on it goes and me
spending time on it and asking for help
i think i'm going to move on to the
private space like i said and just
future developments all going to be
private basically
but i will leave the thing up there
so yeah what would it take for me to
continue this publicly um well i thought
well what if let's let's talk talk
financials would i continue to do
publicly for a hundred dollars
no rather do privately but all 200 200
wait how much 200 per year no per month
yeah we're talking per month 200 per
month and i'd still rather do it
privately okay what about 500 if we paid
you 500 a month would you continue to
talk about this and develop it publicly
and teach us now i couldn't really
sustain myself on 500 i think i'm going
to decline i'll just do it privately and
you know find other work or do work
differently so even for 500 a month you
won't continue to develop this well i'll
continue to develop it just not publicly
and yet 500 too little that's not
something i can live off of so no so i
just like kind of ran down and asked
myself these questions and the number
that i arrived at where i would be happy
actually working on this publicly and
continuing is like a thousand dollars
and uh that doesn't really mean anything
honestly i mean it does but i'm trying
to think how to word this i guess i i
just mean to say that i'm not concerned
like i don't expect to ever hit that
number if i do awesome i'll be a man of
my word and
and do what i'm supposed to do but i
just don't expect it so there's no
disappointment if i don't hit it but
yeah i will put the thing up here i'll
put it up on the repo and if one day it
gets to a thousand dollars a month i
will continue we'll see how this code
vlog series plays out as of right now
there are some people who seem to like
it but it does rather poorly on my
channel compared to my main videos
uh but it does take a lot less time to
produce so there's like a little give
and take there so yeah it's it's a tough
decision to make i guess what i'm saying
there about what it to do
ultimately but yeah i think i'm just
gonna settle on that uh yeah i'm gonna
fix it up a little bit make it actually
usable test it some but then from there
development will stop and i'll go to my
private project unless we happen to meet
that funding goal i think that's the
right choice now this is a very personal
choice i can't imagine how this would
upset anybody in any way
i'd be really surprised if it does
because there have been
zero people who have directly expressed
interest in this project continuing some
people will support me and give a like
and i appreciate that and that sort of
thing but in general i don't think
there's a single person out there who is
concerned whether i continue or not and
if if i'm wrong on that which i could be
then i expect them to let me know and if
they don't let me know then so be it you
know part of life is you just can't
expect every single thing you do to be
successful sometimes you just got to
make the choices to move on and cut off
things that aren't working
and that's sort of what this is about
i'm really excited to continue
development i'm really excited to work
on it make a game
but i'm not particularly excited to try
to impress people that don't really care
you know and i i feel like more people
should adopt that attitude and we'd be a
lot happier it's incredibly stressful
and a waste of time to try to impress
people that don't care and uh yeah i
don't know sorry sort of rambling but i
just wanted to share some thoughts with
you and uh kind of explain my train of
thought and why
because in the future if i just did this
and didn't say anything someone would
ask a million questions and i'd be
annoyed but now i can just say i go just
do you know did you watch the vlogs
about it okay well that explains it all
especially the last one about where it
went so
i don't yeah also sometimes i get these
comments like why didn't you continue
this series
and i'll think back to that time and
i'll be like well because when i
released the video it got like two views
and then it wasn't until like a year
later that it actually had some feedback
so you know by a year later i had so far
moved on from this video
like can i can i help it that no one
watched to begin with maybe a little i
could have like dumped tons of ads into
it i could have
tweeted it and retweeted it and posted
on reddit all this but i'm not that guy
you know i am not an advertiser i
i'm not a businessman
i know this is strange probably a lot of
people but i don't care about hardly
anything other than like programming and
how the inner workings of things are i'm
just that sort of person i like the
really fine details if you try to
blast me with media that is just trying
to get me to buy something that looks
cool i'm going to be annoyed and i
wouldn't try to do that to other people
in general if i ever have in the past i
was probably forcing it and i don't
intend on doing that kind of thing again
all right well that's enough of the
rambling for this i think that's it see
you guys later alright he's now bite
check the links check those fund the
project if you want to see it continue
publicly
[Music]
[Music]
you